one member of the president's family is
weighing in on the impeachment effort to
CBS News in a rare interview set to air
later this month on Face the Nation
Ivanka Trump told Margaret Brennan that
despite those concerns getting impeaches
actually energized her father your
father has now been impeached she is now
only the third u.s. president to go
through this what has been the impact
has he made peace with it he's energized
as are 63 million-plus voters who
elected him to office this is historic
as you know in in many ways including
the fact that it is the first purely
partisan impeachment I'm surprised to
hear you say energize because when I
read the letter that your father sent to
Speaker Pelosi he seemed angry and in
fact he wrote you do not know nor do you
care the great damage and hurt you've
inflicted upon wonderful and loving
members of my family was that a
reference to you I don't think the words
are mutually exclusive you can be angry
at a process that is unjust so there is
there can be anger anger at the
opportunity cost to the Americans we're
all here serving and what could have
gotten done angry at the waste of time
angry at the collateral damage angry but
it's still energizing and it focuses you
on really in draws into relief the stark
contrast in priorities Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan joins us now
Margaret listen nobody has a better
insight into the mind of her father than
Ivanka Trump she's his adviser and of
course she's his daughter so how do you
think this whole process is affecting
her why did she want to talk the day
after the impeachment vote well you know
Gail Ivanka Trump wants her father and
the history books to be written about
the initiatives that she thinks have
made a difference and she described all
this as raw politics she described as
divorced from reality and even though
but vote happened the night before she
still came and sat for this long planned
interview on paid family leave she has
championed this issue in particular
because even though it's a democratic
priority not a Republican one it's part
and parcel of how her family has
basically reshaped Republican priorities
you know the United States has long been
one of the few developed countries in
the world that doesn't require employers
to pay employees during their 12 weeks
of leave following giving birth or
adopting a child and that changes today
when President Trump signs a law that
includes the first update to it in
nearly 30 years and it's going to
guarantee US government employees that
they will receive paychecks during that
leave there the country's largest
employer and this may change policies
for actual private companies that's what
Ivanka Trump wants the country to be
focused on and clearly it wants to hold
impeachment at arm's length but we will
have that paid family leave story for
you at the end of the year all right a
lot of people will be glad to hear that
and as you point out she could have
easily cancelled and she did not thank
you Margaret on Face the Nation this
Sunday Margaret we'll talk to a
Republican senator roy Blunt and
democratic senator chris van hollen
you